vertriebs er macht eine oder hat eine so
gute sendung gemacht eine super
sensationelle wahlsendungen hat man
wirklich das habe ich auch schon gesagt
fand ich sensationell du hast aus
nachgebauten oval office berichtet und
das 18 stunden lang achtung überleitung
waren sie schon beim auslauf ist im
weißen haus ja bei ihr haben beiden hart
betroffen
dann machen sie da drüben schon mal
politisch unterwegs ja aber nicht im
oval office und die nähe zu ein tramp
hätte ich auch nicht gesucht
glaub ich ihnen irgendwie patricia
behinderten wm was sagt dass überhaupt
über den menschen trump asis ist es
immer so wahnsinnig leicht seine politik
zu kritisieren und zu sagen er ist aus
dem pariser klimaschutzabgabe
ausgetreten er hat dies gemacht er
umarmt diktatoren und sagt er hat sich
in sie verliebt ist das in der sachen
die wir alle schon wissen ich fragte
mich schon wenn sich jemand zum gewinner
erklärt bevor der wettbewerb wurde in
dem sinne die wahl jetzt hier überhaupt
zum zum abschluss kam was sagt das
eigentlich über einen charakter aus
ich hab das verglichen damit das amt wie
so ein business manager wohnst du clos
du dir so herzlich egal was jetzt hier
passiert ich mag diesen stil zu wie eure
regeln gelten ist mir völlig egal sie es
ähnlich aufgefasst was denken sie
darüber
manche sagen dass man herrn trump mit
den instrumenten der politik gar nicht
erklären kann sondern dass man das mit
den instrumenten der psychologie tun
muss interessant und wie erklären sie
darauf ja also in der politik haben was
natürlich mit ganz vielen leuten zu tun
die gern in der öffentlichkeit stehen
gestalten und so weiter aber ich glaube
dass der der narzissmus die
selbstbezogenheit der der egoismus die
rücksichtslosigkeit die fähigkeit alles
auszublenden was einem nicht selber in
den kram passt dass die bei ihm in einer
weise ausgeprägt ist dass das also aus
der norm rausfällt sage ich dann
demokratisch orientierten menschen ist
man jetzt ja also vor allem ein
antidemokrat na also ich meine man sich
vorstellt was er da gemacht hat dass
kann man vergleichen mit einem 90
minuten spiel und ich höre in der 70
minute auf weil ich in führung bin ja
und das ist genau das was er gerade
versucht gutes beispiel oder also
auch mit dem brief fallen dass er die
einfach nicht anerkennt das ist
antidemokratisch und was mich wirklich
umsorgt ist eigentlich dass er gewählt
worden ist weil es sexistisch ist weil
er rassistisch ist also dass das kein
argument war gegen ihn zu stimmen und
ich meine die trend ja welten die beiden
kandidaten also er lebt von der spaltung
und das ist auch genau das wie er die
mehrheiten generiert und wenn die rede
von biden gesehen hat gestern der der
der hat ja gesehen dass das genau das
gegenteil ist da wird ja auch oft die
gemeinsamkeiten auf die menschlichkeit
auf die harmonie gesetzt und ich glaube
auch du hast vollkommen recht dass er
halt auch so ein modell ist was die
politik extrem herausfordert und das hat
natürlich auch mit dem glasperlenspiel
der eliten zu tun und der ist eine
antwort auf das establishment der ist ja
nicht als alien vom himmel gefallen
sondern die demokraten haben auch viele
fehler gemacht
ja niemand ist fehlerlos aber was ich
mich frage ist warum wählen frauen trump
haben frauen trump gewählt und bei der
afroamerikanischen bevölkerung ist sein
wähleranteil teilweise sogar noch
gestiegen
interessante frage ich klar bei den
frauen in den usa ist es werden für der
erklärung zu suchen aber ich glaube dass
solche sachen wie patriotismus und auch
religion und dort haben ja oft ein
religions- bild in den usa dass ich
völlig unterscheidet von dem was wir
hier haben
von den fundamentalen christen die
regeln haben die uns hier mittlerweile
völlig fremd geworden sind und ich
glaube ihm das einen großen einfluss
hatte auf die wahl und ich glaube dass
er die bizarr also auch sein mag er mit
seiner corona politik bei manchen
punkten konnte indem er sagt bei mir
kommt kein lockdown mehr
das klingt wie eine freiheits verheißung
für viele und auch damit glaube ich kann
er dann ob mann oder frau bei denen die
denkt man kann corona abschaffen als
sei es einfach ein lästiges dinge dass
wir jetzt loswerden müssen kann können
sie punkten ich lernte dort seine hinaus
ein werk glaube was er auch macht das
was viele frauen empfänglich macht viele
oder frauen sind sehr oft empathisch und
sehr oft sensibel und haben wir andere
antennen als männer
und ich glaube dass er hat ja auch eine
sehr sehr starke körpersprache mit denen
er aus so vielen verbales loslässt und
ich glaube dass viele auch dafür
empfänglich sind gewarnt
von der körpersprache war einfach wie er
sich bewegt man merkt richtig finde ich
persönlich bin ob das jetzt reden sind
oder wie er sich auch bewegt verkörpert
nonverbal ganz ganz stark was nämlich
was na ja den retter der mann der
bescheid weiß ich gehe raus er macht
aber auch sein gegner dadurch ganz oft
durch verschiedene gesten ganz klein
indem er entweder gehend oder rum guckt
und symbolisiert damit in dem moment
einfach es ist nicht interessant was
mein gegner sagt ich bin jede bar wo die
ich mache das hier zu ende und das dass
ein magnet ismus für weibliche wähler
ich glaube dass das für viele menschen
aber auch für frauen die doch oft sehr
viel empathischer gestrickt sind oder
sensibler gestrickt sind ich glaube das
könnte eine anfälligkeit sein
da kommt darauf an auf welche da kommt
man sich einfacher und spart auch stehe
ich sage wir wissen doch alle dass
körpersprache und nonverbale sprache
dass das ein ganz ganz groß sein dass er
drei listen aufgebaut hat da gebe ich
dir recht da gibt es ja auch bizarre
bilder und tipps wie er sich da
durchgesetzt hatte wie ihr sich platz
einräumt die ganze körpersprache bei der
zusammenkunft der kanzlerin das
sicherlich was dran ob das der alleinige
grund das weiß ich nicht ich habe nicht
mehr das angebot ist
beide spielten tauchen noch eine rolle
ja und
wahrscheinlich auch keine sehr
unbedeutende was haben sie für einen
eindruck von joe biden ist würde immer
wieder sein alter thematisiert mich zum
beispiel hat er sich dann während der
wahl in einer ansprache an das volk
gewendet hat schon auch er sieht jetzt
sonst immer sagt er es ist egal ob er
der älteste präsident sein wird aber das
ist dass seine frau in einem so
wichtigen moment ihm da einen reden muss
er hat mich zum ersten mal zum
nachdenken gebracht und wir an das
gerade hinter den kulissen diskutiert
und die frage gestellt muss es
eigentlich auch für politiker so eine
art altersbeschränkung bliebe man den
führerschein abgibt man kann keinen
staat mehr lenken
man kann kein auto mehr lenken müsste
irgendwann schluss sein müsste es dort
regeln geben oder spielt in ihren augen
das keine rolle mehr erfahrung um so
besser und entziehen wir den älteren
menschen auch das wahlrecht können dann
die nun nicht gewählt werden oder dürfen
sie auch nicht mehr wählen
ich glaube dass diese einschränkung der
demokratie fände ich nicht gut weil die
menschen können ja entscheiden
traue ich jemandem auch in einem höheren
lebensalter etwas zu oder traurig nicht
zu und nach meiner erfahrung gibt es
sehr viele nicht so aktive und
energetische junge und es gibt sehr
weise und auch noch sehr energetische
ältere also fertig wird das gar nicht
über einen kamm scheren sondern muss
sich die person im einzelnen ansehen der
ronald reagan hat mal gesagt in einem
wahlkampf er würde die jugend und
unerfahrenheit seines gegners nicht
ausnutzen um das alter das argument
umzukehren
mit blick auf joe biden habe ich zwei
gedanken der erste gedanke ist
möglicherweise ist nicht herr beiden
gewählt worden sondern herr trump
abgewählt worden
falls der joe biden erfolgreich sein
wird und zum zweiten will ich mal den
blick darauf lenken dass herr beiden
jahr antritt in einem tandem mit einer
jungen sehr viel versprechendem
vize-präsidentschaftskandidatin die er
mit sicherheit mit bedacht gewählt hat
der vizepräsident ist
man sagt ja immer der vizepräsident ist
ein herzschlag von openoffice entfernt
aber in dem fall jetzt spielt das
natürlich eine besondere rolle und das
wäre doch eine interessante verheißung
für die zukunft wer weiß wann vielleicht
auch erst in vier jahren
eine amerikanische vizepräsident in die
antritt die präsidentin zu werden
[Musik]